In the age of YouTube and fanatic fandoms,
something either has to be a Masterpiece
or an atrocity to garner more views and
attention. But Ahsoka is really neither
of those things and at least to me falls
right into the middle and is just decent.
I’m not going to sit here and complain
about how females have taken over Star
Wars or whatever that complaint is and just
care about the pure quality of the show. There
are definite strengths Ahsoka has and there
are also some big issues that hold it back.
First, going into what I think is the show’s major
flaw that really hindered me from enjoying it is
the fact that there are no stakes or tension.
That’s primarily in reference to an action
perspective, but before going into that, the
show’s inherent premise is already spoiled from
the get-go so you always know exactly where the
story is going, thus destroying any suspense as
to what happens. Because throughout, the show
treats the question and threat as to if Thrawn
is returning as this big point of mystery and
conflict. However, through marketing and them
publicly casting Thrawn, we know right away that
he will return. It becomes this inevitability
instead of a question as to if it will happen.
Nothing the characters do have stakes because we
already know the outcome beforehand. This isn’t
necessarily a fault to the writing and instead
the inherent nature of the show and how it was
packaged. Although, I think the story does a good
job at combatting this by having our protagonists
overcome obstacles in more creative ways after
a simple solution is snuffed out. Like in the
beginning when the information from the puzzle
was stolen and negotiating with a space whale for
safe passage to a new galaxy. So even though we
know the outcome, the process of getting there is
still relatively interesting and not very obvious.
It holds just enough of a hook within the audience
to keep your attention throughout the series. Now
going back to the tension and stakes for action
scenes, this is an aspect about the show that
really drove me crazy. In every single lightsaber
fight scene besides the final fight with Morgan,
where finally someone actually dies, the
heroes and villains walk away unscathed and
it’s as if were just watching skirmishes with no
consequences. It becomes extremely contrived for
characters to survive these combat encounters,
but the creators want to artificially inject more
action into the series. And through each action
scene, they expose the plot armor these characters
are wearing more and more. Like the most egregious
example is Sabine. We have the infamous opening
where she gets skewered by a lightsaber and
is fine, but the writers hilariously do this
again essentially by having Shin simply leave
before killing Sabine in episode 4. She disarms
her and knocks her onto the ground, but Sabine
shoots her once, Shin drops her lightsaber, and
then peaces out with a smoke bomb. Like she could
easily just kill her here since she lost track of
her and can force grab her lightsaber, but heyyy
we need Sabine for later. Then when she shows up
to stop Baylan and grabs the artifact, Baylan can
simply force pull it out of her hand and kill her,
but he instead opts to make a deal to artificially
keep her alive. Every episode is full of these
glaring examples of plot armor and contrivances
to the point that it invalidates all danger. You
know that every single lightsaber fight ends
with no casualties and it’s insane that they
have about 3 of them and nothing major happens.
Without any tension or stakes it makes the action
extremely dull and generally what saves action if
that is the case is great choreography. However,
I wouldn’t say a single lightsaber fight in the
show was remarkable and all came off as being
bland. And the big issue is that we have so many
examples of great lightsaber fights to the point
that if you ever draw a comparison from those to
Ahsoka they utterly blow Ahsoka out of the water.
They aren’t dynamic, the lightsaber choreography
is generally pretty generic with rare spicy moves,
the choreography is at times slow and clunky
as if they didn’t have enough rehearsal time,
and even the locations in which the fight scenes
takes place does nothing for the action. Also,
another aspect that I think hurts these lightsaber
fights is the constant usage of parallel editing.
Now parallel editing is when you cut back and
forth between two separate scenes happening
at the same time within the story. Generally,
this is fine, but the way they utilize parallel
editing in Ahsoka is at times really annoying.
Mainly because they spend all this time building
up to a lightsaber showdown and then the
second they start fighting they cut away
to another scene. It robs you of that excitement
you slowly build up leading to this major moment,
just for it to instantly dissipate. At times
it feels like a copout because their budget may
not be big enough to show us an uninterrupted
lightsaber duel, and instead just small chunks
here and there. I want to see the whole story of
the fight and the ebb and flow of who is winning
instead of jarringly being thrown in and out of
it. Then every other type of action scene is also
plagued with the same issues of constant usages
of contrivances and plot armor. From spaceship
combat being completely nonsensical in which
enemy fighters can endlessly shoot at Ahsoka’s
ship and constantly miss and do nothing.
Or if they do damage it like in the finale,
Huyang is able to repair it in like 30 minutes
somehow and there’s just no consequences. Or the
normal fights with stormtroopers in which they
are never shooting the protagonists when they
are in clear sight. The biggest example was when
they were all surrounded at the end of episode
7 and when Ahsoka shows up they literally all
just start running away instead of overwhelming
her with blasters. Or literally just becoming
immortal and rushing an open field with a star
destroyer reigning hell down on them and none
of them sustaining any casualties. Like I know
Obi-wan and The Book of Boba Fett were bad,
but holy shit these examples are on the same
level and if not even worse at times. I know Dave
Filoni is a more competent writer than Jon Favreau
which I’ll get into in a second, but he still
suffers from regularly using contrivances to
make his story work. The infuriating thing about
Ahsoka is that if these major issues were fixed,
the show would be significantly better. But it’s
just plagued by that cheap Disney+ show feel
where all the action feels rushed, botched
and plagued with apparent writing issues.
Moving onto another aspect, let’s go into the
characters. Ironically, and this is rarely the
case, I loved all the antagonists and none of
the protagonists. I didn’t hate them mostly
think they are pretty generic with not a lot
interesting happening under the hood. Ahsoka
was devoid of personality and was just this
simple zen-like figure. So much to the point
that she kind of gave me pretentious vibes as
to this is how Jedi should act. When in reality,
all the most interesting Jedi characters had very
colorful personalities and had certain quirks that
made them so loveable. Like Obi-Wan’s civil nature
and Anakin’s wreckless albeit effective nature.
Ahsoka doesn’t really have anything going for her
and she mostly comes across as a dull figure. She
doesn’t have a character arc in her own show
and even the quote-on-quote best part of the
series about her flashback doesn’t really add
much to her character. I liked this sequence
and enjoyed it, but if you really take a look
at it within the context of the entire season,
you could effectively remove it and nothing
changes unfortunately. It’s cool to see her
confront Anakin again and their discussion was
infinitely more intriguing than anything with
Sabine, so much to the point that I’d rather we’d
just have gotten a live-action Clone Wars show,
but Ahsoka really doesn’t learn any revelations
along with this introducing more mechanics within
the universe that are confusing. Like if a Jedi
is on the brink of death, do they always go to
this mind palace area where they fight for their
life that conveniently slows down their heart rate
for an hour as they await to be saved? I like
this concept in theory, but it’s implementation
is undeniably messy and kind of confusing. Not
to mention that Hera randomly brings her force
sensitive son to a dangerous combat mission
just so that he can hear Ahsoka and Anakin’s
lightsaber duel. Which essentially brings up the
point that for every good aspect in the show it’s
immediately counterbalanced by something bad. And
my main assumption is that Star Wars fans are more
blind to these faults or are much more accepting
and forgiving of them. I’ve seen Star Wars fans
say this scene gave them full body chills and I
just don’t understand that level of attachment to
this franchise anymore given Disney’s handling
of the IP. Like we were all like that for The
Force Awakens, but in this day and age after so
much heinous shit they’ve done to the franchise,
I don’t have that level of blind hype for Star
Wars and I’m more critical now. Then for Sabine,
I see a lot of hate for her character in that she
shouldn’t be force sensitive, but I don’t care if
she has two X chromosomes. Especially since The
Last Jedi establishes the notion that anyone can
be force sensitive and has to be unlocked with
intense training. And some people are obviously
more powerful than others. I don’t know if people
are just deleting this out of their personal
headcanon, and at this point in the Star Wars
universe, there have been so many cooks in the
kitchen that there is so much conflicting points
within the lore. So since I’m defending her here,
you may assume I like the character, and that
would be wrong because I don’t. I found her to
be largely annoying given her dominant selfish and
rebellious nature. Which is fine from a character
standpoint, but the writers utterly screw her
over in episode 4 by her choosing to condemn
the entire galaxy. She chooses to bring back
Thrawn which will most likely lead to another
war just so that she can see her friend again.
This event immediately disconnects you from the
character and I personally grew so much hatred
for her because of this. Dave Filoni thinks that
this gives the character more depth because she’s
missing that connection of family within her life
but at the entire expense of the galaxy? Really?
It just doesn’t seem justifiable at all and I’m
really surprised she isn’t even condemned for
doing this later on. Like she literally faces
no consequences, or at least so far. There’s also
some other characters that I won’t touch on for
the sake of time like Hera who I thought was fine
and Huyang. Out of all of them though, I actually
enjoyed Huyang the most which kind of feels
sad for the state of the main characters. For
the antagonists, the clear standout is obviously
Thrawn. Like holy shit, I knew he was a favorite
but when he shows up the show goes from mediocre
to great. His screen presence is immediately felt
and surges with so much menacing energy that
you genuinely feel fear just by him staring
at you. Which is also a testament to the
brilliant design of the character. The cold,
calculating, and meticulous nature of the
character is so fresh in comparison to other
empire villains who generally feel more cartoonish
and mustache twirly. He’s never underestimating
his threat and is actually strategizing in real
time against his opponents. Star Wars protagonists
were always able to exploit the fact that
they were underestimated by their adversaries,
but here, it seems like Thrawn is actually trying
his best to win. Although the story is still
pretty contrived in that he could simply order a
tie fighter strike on the hermit crab convoy and
fucking decimate them, but heyyy, what do I know
about military strategy, I just have a useless
bachelors degree in film studies. At the very
least though he actually wins and it makes season
2 or I guess a movie maybe, actually exciting
because there’s a lot of potential for what can be
done with the character and his story. I’d assume
they’d overcome and kill him in the end, but how
much damage he does and who he kills before then
is the main question. Then there are also some
other Sith characters that are generally pretty
intriguing; especially Baylan. The character
has a lot of class and he’s actually honorable
and is pretty witty. He has a lot of depth and
history and like Thrawn, he has a great screen
presence. It’s just too bad that the main story
for his character is primarily being reserved for
the next season and it’s also unfortunate that Ray
Stevenson passed away. Hopefully, they recast him
and don’t leave him on that literal cliffhanger
in perpetual limbo. Then finally we have Shin who
I also think has an infectious screen presence.
She’s so expressive with her eyes and so much hate
pours through them to the point that she’s cutting
into your soul. She does a lot with so little
which I think is a testament to the how great
of an actor she is. Along with her character
having such an off-kilter design that it makes
her general figure kind of disturbing and
terrifying. It’s just a bit unfortunate that
she didn’t have a lot to do within the story
and she was kind of screwed over by the many
contrivances of the writing, but hopefully, she
has a bigger role in season 2 with more of an arc.
Going into some more positives for the
show, I think the overall productivity
and pace was much better than Jon Favaeru’s in The
Mandalorian. Because if this was written by him,
the season would have ended with the reveal of
Thrawn in episode 6 and in that time he would
have injected a bunch of bullshit sidequests
to pad out the length of the season. Instead,
Dave Filoni delivers a real and coherent pace to
the point that it’s funnily a positive aspect now.
Like this should be something that’s a given.
I’ve seen some people still complain that the
show is too slow, but I think a lot of the down
moments are still filled with productive usage
of character development. Albeit, quite a
bit of it isn’t engaging enough to really
be that entertaining. And I understand the
critique that nothing happens in the show,
which is flat-out wrong, but people probably think
that because the show was essentially pitched as
Thrawn returning and that doesn’t happen till the
end of the season. Which again is a problem with
how they sold the show. Dave Filoni at times also
delivers some genuinely great moments within the
story like zombie stormtroopers. I think that
was easily the best setpiece and was actually
a moment where I felt an ounce of danger for
our heroes because the enemy was threatening
for once. Although they’re literally wielding
lightsabers and can dismember them, but whatever,
that’s more of a nitpick instead of a major
issue. Also another aspect about his writing and
his directing that I think he nails is the tone.
It really reminds me of old-school Star Wars and
what it was even inspired by which was Akira
Kurosawa. George Lucas was heavily influenced
by his Samurai films and essentially took the
samurai, gave them laser swords and the force,
and shipped them off to a galaxy far far away
and called them Jedi. Dave Filoni harnesses
this original inspiration and applies it to
great effect in Ahsoka. Like the build-up to
every fight being slow and methodical as
the music slowly builds your excitement.
An example I still love is the first fight scene
where Ahsoka is ambushed by some droids who were
also hunting for the map. Their introduction is
intimidating and mysterious and just hammers home
that samurai tone so well. Just don’t think
about how they don’t instantly activate their
self-destruct and conveniently wait for Ahsoka
to clear the area. Again for every good aspect,
there has to be something that weighs it
down. Then since I briefly brought it up,
I think the music was great throughout the
series. It’s very prominent in Ahsoka and
really emphasizes and elevates each scene. Along
with it expertly punctuating select important
moments. I really love the end credit theme and
pretty much every show besides maybe Obi-Wan
has had outstanding music. The Mandalorian
though is still top tier and that’s just
because Ludwig Gorranson is basically the next
Hans Zimmer. So yeah, from an overall outlook,
I think Ahsoka is kind of mediocre, and just by
having this opinion, I assume this video won’t
do well since I’m not playing to any of the
two extreme sides of love or hate. There’s a
lot more nuance surrounding Ahsoka in terms of
strengths and flaws and to me, the best way to
fix some of those issues is if Dave Filoni wasn’t
the sole writer for the show. Through Andor, we’ve
gotten a taste of what great Star Wars writing
could look like instead of the shallow adventure
we got. Thank you for watching and let me know
in the comments what you thought about Ahsoka.